Артеме Сергійовичу, вітаємо в Німеччині
Перше питання - про актуальне
Ви знаєте, що 26 липня буде засідання комісії
кваліфікаційно-дисциплінарної комісії
де мають винести рішення щодо справи
Назара Холодницького, голови Спеціалізованої  антикорупційної прокуратури
І вже зараз інтернетом
ширяться висновки цієї комісії
де говориться про те, щоб
"винести догану, але не звільняти"
Як того вимагали ви
і вимагаєте
і як того вимагають певні громадські активісти
Я не помилюсь, якщо скажу,
що це не сюрприз для вас?
Ви ж не очікували, що ось так одразу...
- Все буде просто?
Що це буде просто? Чи очікували?
Звичайно, що не очікували
З приводу дати
у мене нема такої інформації,
коли буде засідання комісії
Можу сказати, що я читав
те, що було у публічному просторі,
саме висновок
висновок члена-доповідача комісії
Скажімо так: 53 аркуши висновку
і 52 із них, вони дійсно там
роблять аналіз того, що там відбулося
робиться висновок про те,
що скарга повністю обґрунтована
що всі доводи, які є в скарзі, підтверджені
ці порушення мають характер грубих порушень
які є підставою для звільнення
Але останні півсторінки
це якраз
спроба певної юридичної оцінки
норм закону про прокуратуру
з тим, щоб це все ж таки було
не звільненням, а доганою
Насправді, якщо проаналізувати
закон про прокуратуру
то цей висновок не відповідає нормам
і я сподіваюся
що комісія прийме рішення,
яке є об’єктивне і законне
А ви можете оскаржити це рішення?
Або хтось інший?
Ну, якщо буде догана, то ні
Є така думка, що директора НАБУ
використали в цій справі
щоби, скажімо так, зробити керованим голову САП
Я думаю, ви чули про такі думки
Адже, давайте подивимося реакцію
Генпрокурора на початку справи
Він казав про звільнення.
Зараз він так не висловюється.
Як ви думаєте
Чи це дійсно так чи ні? Ви вважаєте, що вас використали в цій справі?
Ну, я так не вважаю
тому що ініціаторами цього всього були ми
і насправді і Генпрокурор до останнього не знав
що відбуваються такі заходи
тому якраз це було важке рішення
але я вважаю, що ми повинні рахувати
на всі порушення
як з боку тих чиновників, які підслідні антикорупційному бюро
так і з боку працівників НАБУ чи САП
Тому, маючи таку інформацію, ми відреагували
А з приводу коментарів Генпрокурора -
просто він зараз настільки...
я так дивлюся - просто він щас уникає коментарів
можливо, й правильно,
щоб не було певного тиску на комісію
Але ви не вважаєте,
що ви фактично втратили
одного з останніх своїх партнерів?
Тобто, як після цієї справи далі співпрацювати?
Важко співпрацювати, коли...
прокурор каже, що можна там...
вивести фігуранта справи, можна не вивести
Важко співпрацювати, коли прокурор там...
прокурор, який розслідує, приносе підозри
а йому забороняють їх підписувать,
тому що якісь певні ці політичні моменти
При таких умовах важко працювати.
Тому ми на це і відреагували.
Коли ви опублікували ці записи
ви практично пішли ва-банк
Ви таким чином висловилися,
що неможливо співпрацювати більше
з таким головою.
Але що далі?
Тобто, чи не вважаєте ви тоді, що з цього боку
є така також думка, що ви маєте піти у відставку
Якщо ви кажете, що неможливо співпрацювати
з таким головою САП
і якщо врешті-решт він залишається на місці
Чи не вважаєте ви, що тут якось...
Ну, час покаже. Тому що я вважаю
що принциповим для нас є те
що ми повинні рахувати на випадки неправомірної поведінки з боку всіх
в тому числі працівників НАБУ, САП
і у нас є випадки, коли ми детективів
звільняли там за порушення присяги
і це є відкрита інформація
не можна замовчувати те, що відбувається у нас
якщо ми намагаємося когось там
притягнути до відповідальності
Якщо буде рішення таке, що залишать на посаді
наслідки будуть більш глобальні
Прокурор, який вибирає, притягувати чи не притягувати
в залежності від політичної ситуації
Прокурор, який здійснює тиск на суддів, прокурор, який здійснює на своїх підлеглих тиск
певний незаконний - всі ці дії освячуються
і тому наслідки для правоохоронної системи
будуть дуже серйозні
тому, думаю, все ж потрібно
дочекатися рішення комісії
Якщо говорити не про правоохоронну систему загалом, а виключно про вас
Які будуть ваші дії - знову прослуховувати?
Яким чином ви зробите так, що ваш опонент піде?
Ще раз повторю - давайте почекаєм рішення
Тому що є фактаж. І той фактаж,
який зазначений у скарзі, він вже підтверджений
Тобто потрібна тільки реакція
від компетентного органу
в даному випадку компетентний орган -
це комісія прокуратури
Тому я вважаю, що потрібно дочекатись, а потім робить якісь висновки
У себе в кабінеті "жучки" не знаходили?
Ну, поки ні.
Але ви розумієте, що така сама помста
може бути з того боку?
Звичайно.
Насправді, якщо ми говорим там про певну безпеку внутрішню
то в нас в НАБУ єсть Управління внутрішньої безпеки
це управління займається якраз
дослідженням корупційних ризиків в самому НАБУ
На рахунок себе я не переживаю
мене моніторять всі служби України, тому тут, я думаю...
- Прослуховують, маєте на увазі?
- І прослуховують, і спостереження
і повний комплекс всіх заходів.
Тому тут, я думаю, тут я усвідомлюю..
- А ви звідки знаєте?
- Ну, по-перше...
це неможливо по-другому зробити.
Я усвідомлюю, що це є з самого
початку мого призначення
тому я живу і працюю
з усвідомленням того, що це може бути
Ну, поки що до вас не зверталися,
не казали: "Ось є такий запис..."
Справа в тому, що я багато разів казав
про те що якраз рецепт того,
як вижити НАБУ в такій ситуації
це якраз повна відповідність нашої роботи закону
тому дуже важко щось там зафіксувати такого, що...
Про наболіле. Ви, здається, єдиний,
хто вірить словам Президента
коли він каже, що до кінця року, можливо,
те, що запрацює Антикорупційний суд
І здається, якщо я не помиляюся
громадські активісти мають сумніви щодо цього
Ви оптиміст чи дійсно є підстави?
Я одразу уточню, тому що... коли запитують
ставлять питання, наскільки можливо і коли там створення Антикорупційного суду
то я завжди розділяю це питання на дві частини
Перша - це логістична частина
коли ми говоримо чисто логістичну таку складову
я не бачу нічого складного, щоб за сім місяців створити цей суд
І є політична складова
І ми до неї відношення ніякого не маємо.
І це вже політична воля тих
людей, які відповідають за процес створення
Якщо буде політична воля його створювати
то його реально створити
за шість-сім місяців
Якщо не буде
його можна створювати декілька років.
Той же самий приклад
ДБР, коли тільки керівники там обиралися два роки
Але ж, здається, ви казали в одному зі своїх попередніх інтерв'ю
що потрібно щонайменше 97 суддів
але як можна за півроку набрати стільки кандидатів
Ну, у нас є досвід створення Верховного суду
коли конкурс почався в жовтні 16-го
і закінчився в липні 17-го, потім були призначення і запуск Верховного суду
І це трохи складніша структура...
чим Вищий антикорупційний суд, тому в принципі логістично
зробити це в межах шести-семи місяців
дуже реально
Вас не дивує, що кожного разу, коли подавали законопроект
про Антикорупційний суд
з Адміністрації президента називали його таким,
що відповідає всім вимогам Венеціанської комісії
а потім врешті-решт там знову щось з'являлось
як цього разу з нормою про апеляцію
Чому так відбувається?
Насправді норма про апеляцію якраз в проекті президента була зовсім іншою
Це якраз вона з’явилася вже після того, як було проголосовано цей закон
Мене дивує інше
Коли мене питають,
які ви недоліки бачите в цьому законі
Мене запитали, коли не було опубліковано ще остаточний текст цього закону
я тоді відповідав
що головний недолік цього закону в тому, що він прийнятий
на два роки пізніше, чим повинен був
Є цей нюанс з приводу апеляції
Сподіваюся, що він буде виправлений, тому що, наскільки я знаю, внесено у парламент
законопроект, який виправляє цю ситуацію
Але це вже дуже запізніла реакція
В принципі ми ще влітку 2017-го року
чули, що ми не Уганда
що ми не будем створювати цей суд
- Ви маєте на увазі заяви Президента?
- І не тільки.
Потім риторика змінилася
Мабуть, це пояснюється тим,
що лише конкретні приклади тих справ
які ми розслідуєм, які ми направляєм в суд
і коли... ці справи зупиняються в суді,
якраз ці приклади дали
остаточне переконання тим модераторам -
мається на увазі
там суспільству і партнерам міжнародним
що цей проект дійсно потрібно підтримувати
Але все одно я вважаю, що це запізніло
і ми втратили два роки
Ви самі сказали про резонансні справи,
які затягують
одна зі справ, які зараз на слуху
це бурштинова справа. Вже рік пройшов
Чи є якийсь прогрес? Що там відбувається? Чи регрес?
Тому що, якщо я не помиляюсь,
у САП відкривають справу проти детективів
за фальсифікацію
Справа в тому, що останні часи
такі ось рішення САП
вони пов'язані якраз з оцією ситуацією
коли просто банально помста іде детективам за те
що була історія з цим акваріумом
людина, мабуть, захищається від оцього всього
і намагається десь там помститися людям,
які це все робили
Тобто відкриття цих справ було після
скандалу з акваріумом?
Звичайно.
Але, якщо ми говоримо про справу бурштинову, там слідство закінчено
триває ознайомлення з матеріалами справи
зі сторони захисту
і зараз якраз планується передача справи до суду
- Коли це буде?
- Це залежить від САП
Виходячи з того, що зареєстроване це провадження
таке, ну, трохи абсурдне
тому що коли ця робота починалася, то всі матеріали вивчалися
детективами, прокуратурою і тому все було...
Законність всіх дій була вивчена
І чомусь от через рік після того, як усе було зроблено
САП починає там підігрувати підозрюваним
Ну це така банальна помста за ті дії
які були перед цим
Я знаю, що ви не любите, коли у вас питають,
де вироки?
Тобто є скандальні гучні справи
Але, ви знаєте, люди хочуть бачити
корупціонерів за ґратами,
коли вже не просто гучні справи
не просто відео красіве, яке залили в інтернет показали, як це відбувається
а вже остаточне рішення
Чи є гарантія того, що як тільки запрацює Антикорупційний суд
почнуться, скажімо, як в народі кажуть, "посадки"?
Якраз це і було основним аргументом для створення цього суду
Дійсно, якщо подивитись інформпростір України
то такі політикани, критикани, вони якраз використовують
відсутність цих вироків
як предмет для критики антикорупційного бюро
Це величезна проблема
тому що навіть якщо ми переконаємо суспільство
що ми не маємо відношення до винесення вироків
це задача суддів
Наша робота фактично, якщо прочитати закон, закінчується в момент того
як детектив переконав прокурора
що достатньо доказів для передачі справи до суду
І, в принципі, у нас більше немає компетенцій
Ми не можемо приходити до судді,
підштовхувати його до якихось рішень
прискорювати цей процес
Але ми розуміємо, що
і це, до речі, демотивує не тільки суспільство
це демотивує самих детективів
які ризикують там своїм життям, здоров'ям
не бачить сім'ю, працює, передає справу до суду
і вона зупиняється - це демотивує самих детективів
тому що він не баче, а для чого він працює взагалі
Тому це величезна проблема, і я сподіваюся
що якраз-от створення Антикорупційного суду цю проблему вирішить
і ці справи будуть слухаться набагато швидше
якщо ми зараз...
розмовляємо на території Німеччини
то якраз нам колись презентували справу одну
вона стосувалась там розкрадання коштів
державних коштів
по одному там об'єкту і там було сказано
що в справі було майже 90 підозрюваних
і ця справа була розглянута в суді
за три місяці. Я не знаю, скільки вона розслідувалася
Вона була розглянута за три місяці в суді
Але суд відбувався кожен день
- Ви таке хочете теж в Україні?
- Звичайно.
НАБУ нарешті обрало аудиторів. Ви ними задоволені? Цими кандидатами?
Ну, по-перше, я в незалежності від персоналій
не повинен бути задоволеним той, кому призначається аудит
Ну ви ж казали про одного з таких, кого... Верховна Рада одразу ж почала критикувати НАБУ
Це було давно
і це такий був
була спроба
в парламенті провести людину, яка підпише негативний висновок
не заходячи в НАБУ
Ми кажемо про Брауна?
Так
Серед тих, кого обрали, ви бачите когось... упередженого?
Я з ними особисто не знайомий.
Тому... час покаже
На мою думку, своє завдання з приводу призначення аудитора
належним чином виконав уряд
Це було рік назад, навіть більше, по-моєму
наскільки я пригадую, в травні 2017 року
Був оголошений конкурс відкритий на аудитора
НАБУ з боку уряду
Була проведена процедура
і була призначена людина
більше року вже - і не було ніяких скандалів
в парламенті ми бачили якийсь такий серіал
мексиканський, дуже довгий
тому зараз, я сподіваюся,
що ці люди, вони усвідомлюють свою відповідальність
і ми постійно говорили про дві речі.
Перше, що ми не боїмося аудиту як такого.
Тому що нам дійсно є, про що розповісти.
І друге, ми сподіваємось
що довіра до рішення цих аудиторів
чи це буде негативне рішення
чи це буде позитивне рішення - довіра до цих рішень буде... Буде.
Є питання звичайно по відповідності там
критеріям до кандидата на аудитора
по квоті Президента
але ми можем це лише коментувати, ми не можемо впливати на це рішення
На жаль, ми бачимо, що цей процес від самого початку був дуже заполітизований
і ми розумієм, що це
такий спосіб все-таки приборкати оце
бюро, яке там всім заважає...
Але, я думаю, ви для себе вже визначили
хто більш-менш добре оцінить діяльність НАБУ,
а хто ні
Чесно кажучи, ні
в нас перед цим, ми...
проводили - ну, не ми, а фахівці з боку американської сторони, ЄС
проводили оцінювання нашої роботи
ми все це просили зробити для того, щоб для себе розуміти
що ми робим правильно, що ми робим неправильно, що можна зробити краще
і це якраз оціювання дало там
дуже багато рекомендацій
як покращити цю роботу
тому ми в принципі для себе розумієм
і це була дійсно така перевірка людьми
які мають величезний досвід цієї роботи
тому ми для себе розуміли, що ми, ну
десь ризикували, але ми пішли на це,
тому що я вважаю це нормальним
коли державний орган підлягає там незалежному аудиту
для того, щоб зрозуміти, що ми робим правильно,
що ми робим неправильно
Якщо ми проаналізуєм закон
закон про національне антикорупційне бюро
який регулює процедуру проведення аудиту
то дійсно там є велика прогалина з приводу порядку проведення аудиту
і методології
Тому є предмет аудиту, він складається з двох частин
Перша це...
ефективність роботи Бюро
і друга це незалежність роботи
Ну, з приводу незалежності, мабуть
на мою думку, якраз дуже багато доказів незалежності
тому що влада дійсно постійно намагається нас
там знищити, чи приборкати, чи тиснути
І тут якраз аудит дуже простий в цій частині
Але в частині якраз ефективності,
це оціночне поняття
Ефективність оцінюється вироками чи
ефективність оцінюється провадженнями?
Ніхто не знає
Це ми цитуєм норму закону
А що під цим розуміється, ніхто не знає
Яким чином це перевіряється там
на протязі якого сроку
- Це законом не визначено.
- Тобто, ви не можете сказати
"Вироків мало, а там Ситник погано попрацював і НАБУ теж". Так не можна сказати?
Важко оцінити ефективність НАБУ
не оцінюючи ефективність прокурорів
і не даючи оцінки роботі судів
які розглядають ці справи
тому це таке, дуже оціночне поняття
як все це буде використовуватися в ході аудиту
ну дуже важко сказати
Останнє важливе питання: у вас точно в кабінеті нема акваріума?
Насправді, це не привід для жартів
тому що не тільки в акваріум можна поставити насправді
Я маю на увазі, точно не знаходили "жучків"
Точно не було?
Ще раз повторю, що ми працюєм
з оглядкою на те, що все можливо
і директор НАБУ, і заступники директора НАБУ
детективи, керівники детективів
вони працюють з оглядкою на те,
що це може бути
тому гарантувати
з урахуванням прогресу там, розробки спеціальної техніки
що там нічого немає - ну це зараз ніхто не може.